this is Startalk and now for the part of
star talk we call how tweet it is and
all I do here really is go back to some
tweets I posted and reflect on them give
some of the backstory and right now I've
got with me in studio Bill Nye so good
to be you know tweeting the code
tweeting he's a tweeter himself finally
you change your Science Guy
hey somebody let it go so I was able to
snare it Bill Nye yeah so now you water
let-up know you're nice February 17th
2015 was really cold in New York and
people started saying well if there's no
global warming so I thought let me find
the 10 coldest ever recorded
temperatures in New York and we're back
more than a century but less than two
cent less than two centuries at the
record the database and that all 10
coldest temperatures occurred before
1944 yeah as an example so I posted them
all in Fahrenheit and then people say
what a plus then I realize I have a lot
of followers around the world and no one
else uses Fahrenheit so then I
resubmitted them in Celsius ok yeah but
then I still colder it's then I said
while I'm doing it let me keep going and
ice then I gave them all in kelvins yeah
yeah so I said the ten coldest
temperatures ever recorded in New York
City 252 2050 to two hundred fifty to
two hundred fifty to two hundred fifty
to two hundred fifty one 2051 251
Twitter 43 minutes 247 kelvins all
before 1944 and it turns out people were
more enchanted with that tweet than the
Fahrenheit tweet or even the Celsius
tweet well you built a following of
temperature monitors and notice
everybody you don't you don't say
degrees Kelvin the Kelvin is its own you
exactly it's kelvins so I said okay if
you're a Kelvin wienie then perhaps
you're a favourite cold temperature
because someone asked me what's my
favorite temperature your favourite cold
temperatures are clearly zero
well maybe it's or three but entry
Kelvin background what's background temp
3 degrees Kelvin yeah yeah yeah two
point zero three Kelvin Kelvin yeah and
so he's never done people where and of
course the zero do we come in intersects
their rank
scale the ranking tell us what the
rankings wankin is mr. engineer
yeah Rankin is a Scottish engineer who
established an absolute temperature
scale with Fahrenheit degrees as opposed
to Kelvin Kelvin which is an absolute
temperature scale with Celsius or
centigrade old old nomenclature degrees
and you have to have it you cannot do
air conditioning problems we would not
be able to have this conversation you
would not have fuel injection cars heck
we wouldn't have had steam engines to
get the whole industrial age started if
we didn't understand absolute
temperatures nice nice and so the
ranking scale and Kelvin scale equal at
zero but after that they go off their
merry ways yeah and my favorite
temperature its 460 Rankine is very
close to 460 below zero below zero
Fahrenheit Fahrenheit and so my favorite
temperature in the in on Fahrenheit and
Celsius is what of course zero no no
it's for at forty boy that's where they
cross that's where they cross exactly if
you have two ladders have rungs this
different distance apart
different height apart but at some place
the two rungs are the rungs on the two
ladders line up and that's minus 40
Celsius or minus 40 Fahrenheit back to
you nail you got it that's been star
talk radio I'm your host Neil deGrasse
Tyson bill thanks for helping me out
here on how to eat it is as always I bid
you to keep looking up this is Startalk